I have you written this letter now
specifically what I've been thinking
about it for a long time I mean you know
I think you may remember my partner
Fiona she resigned for the Labor Party a
year ago now and we've talked about a
lot since then virtually every day and I
think the final sort of coalescence as
it were me decided this was the right
thing to do I was I've just been in
Australia and it was listening to labour
politicians there telling me how they
just have not faced up to the reality
that they all knew which was that the
country were not going to elect their
leader as Prime Minister and and that
was a leader Bill Shorten whose poll
ratings were way out of what jeremy
corbyn's are now and I think also it's
seen the complete lack of strategic
response to the arrival of a new prime
minister I mean Boris Johnson's come in
he's going he's boxed himself into a no
deal bracelet situation whether he
realizes that or not I think he does he
doesn't believe he can win a referendum
No Deal against no breaks it I think no
breaks it wins by a landslide so his
only hope is he gets a mandate through a
general election he blames Europe he
blames Parliament he blames the civil
service he blames business he then sets
up for a general election because he
doesn't think the the country will elect
Jeremy Corbyn his prime minister and I'm
afraid I think the country has decided
about Jeremy Corbyn I think all of the
things that we've heard so much about
whether it's his failure to lead on
breaks facing both ways it's
anti-semitism it's this hard left
sectarian nasty politics that he's come
to maybe not represent but he certainly
is unleashed or allowed to be unleashed
inside the Labour Party and I think the
country looks at the choice we have now
a Prime Minister Johnson or Corbin and
just millions of people just feel no
we're not having this what do you want
to achieve what do you hope to achieve
from writing this letter of making it
public I mean in the end the reason I
guess I've ended up thinking about this
so deeply is because I did get expelled
from the Labour Party for voting Liberal
Democrat tactical in the European
elections I've been going through the
process of an appeal I've got what my
lawyers considered to be an absolutely
watertight case but it's just I've
distorted in a sense I guess what I'm
trying to achieve is is to get one to
try to persuade the country to wake up
to just how bad things are gonna be
Boris Johnson drives through this No
Deal breaks it but it's also to
basically to say what I know so many
Labour MPs and so many labor members
think which is that the Labour Party is
not in a winning position so I guess
what it's doing is trying to speak truth
to power which you know I'm no longer
the kind of the player if you like
inside the top echelon of the Labour
Party that once I was I saw what I can
do is that I'm speak truth to power keep
trying to fight to get the referendum on
brexit that I think the country needs
and wants and is entitled to and but
just do that I guess now from the
context for the first time in my life of
not being inside the labour party
are you trying to I don't know embarrass
or or poke him because as you say you're
not you're not the influential figure
that you were during you know 1997 and
after that during the ten years of Tony
Blair and is it not reasonable to say
that Corbin does still have an awful lot
of support amongst grassroot labour
members well I say my letter that if
there was a leadership election tomorrow
he would probably win it again but I
think he's gone beyond that is gone
beyond the who's up and who's down
inside the Labour Party I think the
country is facing a moment of absolute
peril I think that we've now got this
ill qualified ill-intentioned populist
right-wing leader who has become leader
with a different set of Lies to the lies
that he told to win the referendum and
labour is just they're not remotely in a
winning position and I don't think
that's unfair to point that out I think
that it's you know if you go back you
mentioned 1997 if you go back to 94 to
97 and indeed before that under Neil
Kinnock and John Smith the work the work
rate that you have to have to ask the
city and government and I just don't see
I see complacency I see an irritation
whenever he's asked about brexit or
anti-semitism I see him just not rising
to the challenge and I and I think it's
I think we've just got to stop
pretending that somehow it's all going
to be fine women right because it's not
unless there is major radical change top
at the top who is it whoever takes you
more is it Jeremy Corbyn or is it Boris
Johnson it's not a question of being
irritated I I actually look I really
really really dislike Boris Johnson for
what he represents I think he's a
charlatan I think he's a liar I think
he's a journalist who's never stopped
being a journalist I think he's a
disaster for Britain and that came home
to me when I was in Australia last week
where people were just saying my god
what is your country doing having him as
Prime Minister I had to explain it was
the Tory Party the pictum and no this is
not personal against Jeremy Corbyn it
really isn't I think he's done a lot of
good things I think he campaigned in the
last election a lot better than I
thought he wouldn't look better than
other people did but that just made me
angry that he hadn't campaign like that
in the referendum campaign but a lot of
what I've seen since then it just isn't
stepping up to the to the challenge
that's facing him in this face in the
country and I think the country is in
despair about this millions of people
are looking at that choice now for Prime
Minister Boris Johnson or Jeremy Corbyn
in total despair and I think we've just
got to be honest about that if not
Jeremy Corbyn then whom leading labour
or leaving the country let's go with
labour to start with well I don't I
don't want to kind of put out names and
this and as I said in the piece this is
not part of some kind of plot going on
to you know get somebody else in there
or new party any of that stuff I'm not
involved in any of that this is just a
very personal decision about my position
within the labour party but I think
there are good people in the labour
party but in the end you don't know
until they get there you don't know
until they get close to these top
positions of whether they can whether
they can do it but I think that you know
that it's not just about Jeremy Corbyn
if I look right across the piece
about how many of the how many of the
front bencher even known by the public
how many of our policies are even known
by the public and that's because that
basic professional campaigning just
doesn't it seem to me go on and one of
the other points I'll make is that you
know they the the record of a three-term
Labour government the only time that has
ever happened in our history and here's
the thing Kay eton college that one
school which frankly ought to be in
special measures for the damage its
heaped on our country through Cameron
and Johnson and re smog and the rest of
them that one school has produced three
times more Prime Minister's in our
history than the Labour Party that just
underlines how hard it is to win power
in this country for when you come in
from the left so I just think you've got
to you've got to call it out truthfully
but it was ever thus you know it's
always been harder for labour to win a
general election has it not then the the
right wing of the country but from what
you're saying I'm from picking up from
what from how you're describing your
views at the moment it's the left the G
within the whole party it's not just at
the top it goes right down through the
party and you know people like I don't
know Yvette Cooper people like that and
not potentially doing what they should
be doing I'm guessing I don't know
interesting to hear your views to try
and lift the body up again but listen I
think that I say in my piece which
people can read the whole thing it's in
the in on the new European website and
extracts are in The Guardian but I make
the point that this is much harder for
MPs than it is for me I'm not an MP I
don't not a candidate it's much harder
for them they're in there they have to
go out to their constituents and argue
for a Labour government knowing that
that means jeremy corbyn's prime
minister when most of them are a lot of
them certainly don't think that's
actually credible but I think people I
give that and Hilary Benn in other words
others have made huge contributions from
the back benches but I think people look
at both front benches at the moment and
that new government I mean it's just
desperate you see pretty Patel is the
Home Secretary Gavin Williamson is the
education secretary these are people who
what they've been in their path
as ministers if they were head teachers
or chief of police they wouldn't get
another job and now they're back in even
more senior important positions and that
only happens if the opposition is weak
enough to let it happen so I just think
you know IIIi do get very angry about
this I get but it's the government that
makes me most angry because they
completely screw in the country breaks
it is a disaster Johnson is a disaster
but that's why you need it's so bad any
half-decent opposition right now with a
proper strategy a Blee led with a good
team they be destroying these people and
it's just not happening so why aren't
you stepping up to the plate to do well
to potentially Peter's happy well I
could listen I know I've left but you
know I've been labor all my life I have
been the first election that I voted in
how old Wilson was prime minister I
stuck with labor
whereas admittedly as a journalist but
also as a close friend of Neil chemic
through the whole militant time I
supported Michael foot against Margaret
Thatcher you know I've always been late
but I couldn't imagine supporting
another party but I do think that it's
think something is gonna have to give
this is unsustainable Johnson against
Corbin is the choice for leading our
country at this critical time in our
history
it's an unsustainable choice something
has to give now what role I play in that
I don't even know because I haven't even
thought about it
I've just it's taken me a long time to
reach this decision that I've reached
today I've been I'm a ruminating sort of
person and I've been ruminating a lot
but I've and I feel now that I you know
I'm still kind of a bit you know pretend
that is a hundred percent black and
white I love the Labour Party I think
the Labour Party has done so much for
this country and one of the things that
angers me about korban and his team and
the Communists and the style and histor
around him and the sock puppets that
they unleash on anybody who dares
criticize him is that they have done as
much frankly as the Tories to undermine
the record of
a very successful Labor Government's
you've done amazing things for this
country but but why why turn your back
on your party when they need you the
most you know that if that famous phrase
now's the time for all good men and
women to come to the aid of the party oh
to be absolutely Frank a because they're
you know they don't want they don't want
the Blair eyes they don't want the
people in new labor they don't want the
people who won three elections they
weren't to be able to say that was the
past the world began when Jeremy became
leader and we don't meet those people
and this is the other crazy thing about
the way they approach things I mean they
didn't win I met one of I say in my
piece that I met one of jeremy corbyn's
people to talk about my own position in
the party and actually he actually said
at one point when we won in 2017 and I
said hold on a minute he didn't win
we lost Theresa May became the prime
minister you're the opposition still
where the opposition still so that
mentality that says doing better than we
thought we would is winning we were
devastated in 2005 because our majority
had gone from three figures to to you
know that the Labour Party is it's a
party of government and at the moment I
don't see any real credible coherent
strategy that says to me they have
thought through how they're going to
take on and beat populism and Boris
Johnson will you do like chucker Emunah
house and potentially join another party
I don't know I don't know right right at
this moment I just don't know I can't
imagine being anything other than the
Labour but I do think that because of
the unique set of circumstances that
it's happening at the moment but my MP
skier stahma and he was a good MP I will
she may be done a bit more to fight
brexit but he's you know he's done a
very good job in incredibly difficult
circumstances you know whether I'm not
voting for him and I don't know I didn't
vote labour in the European elections
for reasons I set out they were tactical
it might be if I lived in Scotland I
don't know what I'd vote up there if you
know if you live in if you've got a
by-election coming up on Thursday Oh
sorts of things are going to happen in
our politics and this idea of these two
sort of you know bear moth parties that
there forever are going to be going sort
of Tory laboratory labor I just I sense
that's that's changing but and one of
the reasons is that I say in the piece
that politics in the end is not about
people like me and it's not about people
like these people are on Twitter 24/7
sort of abusing everybody who disagrees
with them it's about people who actually
don't obsess with politics and what they
want from their politicians is people
just do a good job in the national
interest and they look at the two main
parties at the moment one has been
captured by the forces of break so one
has been captured by the forces of the
hard left and they're pretty nasty hard
left at that let me sit let me tell you
and in the middle millions of people
just thinking well who the hell do I
support out of this something has to
give and something I believe is going to
give this is unsustainable for a country
as important as ours when you say
something is going to give how do you
see that panning out I don't know I
honestly don't know I think we're living
in incredibly volatile times you know
I'm speaking to you from from France
few years ago most people never heard a
macron he's now the president it's one
of the most important people on the
planet you look at what's what's
happened in America with Donald Trump
the day before he was elected most
people in the world said that guys that
are going to be President
he is and it's terrifying for the world
Boris Johnson is now the Prime Minister
of the UK I can't even believe I'm
saying those words so all I'm saying is
we're living in volatile times tribalism
is breaking down
but those parties and their bonus you've
got a populism of the right now and a
populism of the left you've got Johnson
trying to recreate some mythical sort of
Churchillian fantasy inside his head and
you've got the Labour Party you talk
about having a radical progressive
agenda but actually a pretty backward
looking in a lot of their policies so it
isn't going to work and the country is
going to suffer for it the country's
suffering already is this massive hit on
the pound happening it's not kind of
technical it's happening because the
world is looking
as the people that I spoke to in
Australia to a man and women last week
didn't be a single blow met one I met
one person who thought that actually
this Boris Johnson thing could work for
the country
I met one guy who thought the brexit was
a good idea they can the world is
looking on us we're a global joke at the
moment and I guess what it is I'm you
know fed up in common with millions of
people I'm fed up pretending that
actually you know it's probably all
going to work out okay
the way things are it's not going to
work out okay so if there was a fantasy
ballot paper where you could vote for
either Jeremy Corbyn or Boris Johnson
what would you do is spoil your paper
that is a hard one that is a hard one
and I know a lot all right Labour MPs I
mean you don't remember the last
election and Lenin labour candidates
went round knocking on doors and they
said look vote for me to be your MP but
don't worry we're not going to win some
of them even put that on their leaflets
so it's a difficult one I think deep
down oh you know on the campus I'm
always gonna be more labour and I could
never ever be a Tory and I could
certainly never ever vote for Boris
Johnson to be Prime Minister and I did
vote for Jeremy Corbyn last time but I
just think that where we are now you
know I mean my partner Fiona she quit
three she quit a year ago the party
we've talked about every day sensitive
it's just a again the three things she
highlighted lack of leadership on breaks
it failure to tackle anti-semitism no
real radical policy thinking that you
know really sort of gave you a sense of
grasp in the future and okay they've
moved in the right direction on break
set to a position that I find much more
palatable but clearly with Jeremy Corbyn
still being dragged kicking and
screaming - it's still determined not to
really get engaged in it and then the
other two I think you can argue that low
party's gone backwards if he does step
down as Labour leader before the next
general election will you renew your
Labour Party membership
depends whether they're dummy back I
guess but III look I don't think it's
just about him I think it's about the
politics that he's allowed to flourish
inside the party and I do think there's
a there's an issue here about some of
the people that he's brought in in
various senior positions who aren't
actually labor who've been communists or
have been stylists or been Trotskyists
who you know but they're now in very
senior positions around him and
controlling the machinery of the party
which is what they're more interested in
and there's always been that element in
the labor party of some people who are
more interested in controlling the party
than they are in winning power in the
country so it would depend if it just
became even if they just sort of
replaced it with somebody's gonna
represent that same politics then I
think that politics has had it I think
the reason why labor is languishing in
the polls is not just about breakfast
it's not just about anti-semitism it's
not just about the division which you
know I accept I'm I'm contributing to I
guess it's about the rejection of a sort
of politics that most people in this
country find unpalatable